duned is unlike anything else that's out
there it is pure cinema
june was the most ambitious movie i ever
done
it's a whole new universe
[Music]
and there were numerous big scale scenes
and i wanted to shoot as much as
possible on camera
[Music]
when your director wants to keep it as
grounded and practical as possible
that's a gift because it feels like
you're able to feed off your environment
bring the scene to life again
i think people are going to be blown
away
benny and i start with the illustration
book so everybody knows what type of
movie they're working on
[Music]
patrice's artwork was incredibly
influential it has a size and scale that
we were after so we built sets to the
edges of the stages
[Music]
i just couldn't believe how massive they
were
i walked onto the stages my jaw
dropped
the sets are
exquisite
and we had scenes out in the desert that
denise and i wanted this place to feel
like you're opening the world up
[Applause]
because there is this amazing crazy
landscape that you will never believe
that they are real
june is a movie about nature and it was
very important for me to be as close as
possible
he knows exactly what he wants he's
loved this book since he was 14 he's had
this movie in his mind his whole life
so there's an aesthetic to this film
that's just different
[Music]
doing for me is a love letter to the big
screen and that's the way it was dream
that's the way it was designed that
though it was achieved and that's the
way i hope people will experience it
i must not fear
where the fear is gone
only i will remain
wow
[Music]
you